a couple of hours ago all of us found
out that that Joan Rivers had had passed
I know very loudly it's and and I and I
know and I bring it up because I must be
acknowledged first of all and second I
know that you had a personal connection
with Joan Rivers I had gotten to be
friends with Joan whom I adored I
actually got to see Joan open for Johnny
Carson when I was a kid in Vegas Mike in
Las Vegas it was the opening act yeah I
mean my parents took me I wasn't like a
four year old who was like let's go to
Vegas like I was we were there and and
met her there and and I got to be
friends with her again you know a couple
years ago and what was the nature of
your connection just the last couple of
years because she she went to you for
advice isn't that true yes yes she was
Carrie you know she I would get a call
from every once in a while I get a
message like Chris it's Joan listen I'm
on the phone it's Joan I want to know
about the internet like she wanted to
know about the internet which is one of
the reasons why I think she was so
relevant for like six decades is that
she wanted to know how everything worked
and how people were communicating now
and she you know she wanted understand
digital content and and I adored her and
she was lovely and a pioneer but also
never stopped working and just like such
an inspiration and it's I'm so I've been
hard working about it all day you know I
wanted to obviously people of all
different ages have their own sort of
snapshot of someone like Joan Rivers for
me and I don't know what it's like for
you any but for me when I was a kid and
I would watch Johnny Carson and Johnny
Carson would occasionally take some time
off and he'd have a substitute fill-in
and Joan Rivers when would fill in for
Johnny Carson and when she did it was an
event everybody I mean everybody in the
country would talk about it the next day
it hard to in that media is so fractured
now there's so many thousands of
different shows and everybody competing
for attention it's hard to explain to
people today what an event that was she
would go on she would guest host for
Johnny Carson and everybody people would
gather in the living room the next
everyone would howl with laughter the
next day they would talk about it
because at that time she was so so
outrageous you know and and and her her
comedy it felt so out of the bounds and
people were just blown away yeah I mean
she never lost her edge like she was an
edgy comic I mean I've been doing
Comedy Tour with people like Bill Berlin
louis c.k and sarah silverman and and
everyone just always talks like oh but
joan is you know like she hated the word
legend because she always something like
oh it makes me sound old but she really
was like she did so many things and
broke down so many barriers and and and
did it up until right before she passed
away so it's a tragedy that's the other
thing too is so many people talk about
women women in comedy and and the
progress and the fact that more and more
hilarious women are knocking down
barriers left and right or are there
barriers anymore but she would when she
was being funny on The Tonight Show
you'd sit there and the entire family no
matter what age you were you weren't
thinking this is a woman being funny
she was just hilarious gender was
completely irrelevant in the things that
you're saying I'd also agree with but
but just as a comedian yeah you know
like like no no gender lines at all she
was just one of the best performer
comedian stand-up writers and if you
guys ever get a chance you should watch
her documentary called a piece of work
which yeah gives you just a little bit
of insight into how her brain works but
also such a lovely woman so sweet so
generous and so you know it's a kind of
notice that no buts but she deserves
respect and a huge round of applause
[Applause]
you